let's go next to
uh oh i don't know we've been we've been
so in the u.s
today let's try peter from dublin
peter you're on the air hi david how are
you doing
i'm doing well long time listener first
time caller uh pleasure american
politics is a bit of a
guilty pleasure for me i suppose uh wow
maybe i used to be a fan of that classic
fantasy series the west wing many years
ago
yes i just wanted to say that i i really
really enjoy
listening to your balanced well-informed
commentary about
politics so thanks for that
my general comments i do have one more
specific
thing so it is related to the commentary
uh
piece so it's about marjorie taylor
green
favorite character i'm sure so i'm just
wondering don't you think that
mainstream media are making the same
mistake in relation to her that they did
with trump
and and what i mean is they give her a
lot of free
screen time every time she says
something completely absurd or you know
outrageous and we know she does that a
lot so will does not promote a
dangerous character even further like it
seems to be already happening if you
look at her fundraising figures and
you know the mainstream media are known
the wiser after how they promoted trump
in 2016 and like she knows very well how
trolling works
so wouldn't be just safer to just you
know to not feed the troll
and and uh ignore her stupid comments
instead of going yeah
it's another stupid thing i know she's a
member of congress
but what do you think about that here's
the problem this comes up all the time
this
this is an ongoing question um here's
the problem
if serious media
and left-wing media ignores her
uh and right-wing media continues to
hold her up
as a hero that is the only
message that gets out now you might say
well right wing media only talks about
her because she's so triggering
to normal media and left-wing media i
don't think that that's the case
i think that this is someone who because
of her personality and because of her
affiliation with trump
is popular in right-wing media now is
there some degree to which you're right
that as she gets more media coverage
right-wing media becomes even more
sycophantic about her and gives her more
coverage yeah probably but they would be
covering her anyway and the problem with
not addressing that there is someone in
the house of representatives
who thinks masks are like the holocaust
and i think she was one of the people
with lauren bobert who wants guns on the
house floor and all this different
stuff the problem is that if reporters
ignore it and left-wing media ignores it
the ideas don't go away it is seen
increasingly by the right
as legitimate to have someone like this
in the house of representatives and i
fear that it just grows so i've just not
seen any evidence that
ignoring it quote ignoring it is really
a solution to anything
okay and do you think that she she's
doing that on purpose like
is it a marketing tactics because it
does remind me very much of um
the marketing tactics of the airline
ryanair that's
in the news recently because of what
happened in belarus so yeah
your ceo many years ago like every now
and then he would say something
completely ridiculous
publicly like that he will only
introduce you know one pilot to save
money or or offer standing tickets or
something something completely
impossible with
any rig and all the newspapers at the
time of radio shows would pick it up and
start discussing as if it was a serious
thing and
every time they would say oh low cost
airline locos airlines so
that you know got embedded in people's
brains so
is it possible that she's doing that on
purpose so that you know if as you said
you know if somebody
more right wing leaning will watch you
know mainstream media
they will see her and it will be just oh
look at her owning those lip guards
again you know
like is is this do you think it is she's
smart like this or is it just you know
accidental that
i think that it's a combination i think
to some degree she knows that there are
types of things that she can say that
will get her attention
a lot of it isn't good attention i don't
think she's so brilliant at it though
that she's doing it in a way that really
benefits her i think there's a good
chance she gets absolutely crushed
in in november of 2022 and then that's
it for her
so i think that it it it works in
getting her attention right now
whether it will really achieve or serve
some bigger purpose
i don't know i think it actually could
be disastrous for her
david thank you very much uh much
appreciated all right
shaylen from ireland very much
appreciated thank you so much